hello and welcome to this video playing
maize maze mm-hmm okay and be three
years of rare line then the Sicilian but
not so bad it has been even played by a
chronic of all people so and let's see
what we would we get here I'm have lost
a bit of time down that could be an
issue I hope it isn't hmm seems that is
out for long castling join 7am playing
normal-looking moose hmm okay the long
diagonal that could be an issue mmm I
don't like to take but i think i have 2
95 he will take on d5 take these six and
g7 hangs yeah okay huh okay I was a
little bit more concerned about the f
porn taking this son didn't look that
dangerous to me but maybe I'm wrong so
cancel short and he will go g4 typical
kind of opposite colored opposite card
opposite side castling at the moment the
rookies hanging so he probably will take
on c6 know maybe is shooting for f5
that's also certainly an option
hmm ok and I'll go here I need some
counter play yeah so how how to go for
the counter plaything see form I need to
open up things and 95 app looks ok i
don't i don't and feel like this is so
dangerous Knight f6 maybe but I am
pretty quick here myself with Queen 85
and stuff like that so let's see how is
he covering a two in the first place is
also night before coming I don't didn't
see how he does that isn't night before
strong night before a three night xe2
and bam that looks pretty good
let's go for it check maybe King d3
running away but if he goes back looks
it too looks decisive and that I thought
wouldn't work at all Queen a4 looks it
to check threaten a queen a three but
maybe you can put the Queen on the third
ha you can do that that's pretty bad hmm
it's to play queen bee three I guess
nylander and this is hanging ok yeah
that means i can go here right queen bee
three discrete XD form
so let's do a countdown five against six
so I'm a pawn up hooray
the only thing that is slightly worrying
is that don't have so much space there
under and on the kingside my king is
slightly weak not a huge deal with a
route coming on the eighth-ranked or so
would be it would be awkward okay I have
to check with the pawn that wasn't very
very good okay again don't think it's a
huge deal but it wasn't very precise
and yeah I don't like to trade much but
guess i have to and I could have gone
black okay so king of eight with cheeks
i'm going to take all those pawns that
should be should be okay King be three
hmm it is fairly still fairly tricky
it's got Ruby six and we'll take those
hmm it's not not so great actually let's
see if I can get those pawns
why did I go Kimmy 7 nobody knows what
i'm going to do it now I support this
completely winning position really bad
time when he really badly
amazing what now i'm winning easily
white resigns I should have just won one
in the attack down okay so i think that
was at that was clearly too optimistic
here and now we have see takes and
Bishop e3 is even stronger but I get it
enters win janet is win Bishop a
three-year sir is the killer should have
thought a little bit there I actually
didn't see that he can cover on the
third-ranked very simple reply this is
this is ending the game immediately
check check check no very very soon here
okay but this is also winning but not as
some convincing I should take me three
probably take age to just just grab
things now that was a very bad very
badly played rook rook c8 is just
absolutely terrible I I saw that far too
late that he can can take and this isn't
isn't anything good if the position is
just just equal ish he I should go key
seven I missed that turn yeah here and
this is equal but he has to go a four
and then it's it's just a draw check
something like that will end in a draw i
guess yet here I'm just winning the king
and porn and game so
was very very helpful and then opening
line would be three is not so bad I'm
not aware of the theory I mean that
looked fairly fairly normal at same I
think the main problem was that he has
to hear he has to play differently 94s
just not on it looks aggressive for
Knight f6 or some some kind of fantasy
attack but I'm just [ __ ] Wicca here with
the pawn already and so on some white
has to probably a.m. yeah some something
something small it has to play something
modest them okay well thanks for
watching